China's increasing its military budget
by more than ten percent to better
safeguard its sovereignty the rise
emphasizes the country's intention to
prioritize its military spending even as
its economic growth slows well we spoke
to Abraham Denmark's senior vice
president for security affairs at the
National Bureau of Asian Research in
Washington China's leaders believe that
it requires this kind of investment in
its military capabilities which is a bit
confusing for us outside of China
because if you look at those around
China look at Russia Japan Vietnam their
military spending is much much lower
than what China spends on its military
I'm so you have to believe that it sees
the need to invest in these sorts of
military capabilities and the only
possible target for such a large
expenditure is the United States a lot
of this is uncertain China is not
terribly transparent when it comes to
its defense spending in fact most
outside observers believe that even the
number that china's state institutions
announced for its defense budget aren't
wrong released inaccurate and that it
does not include several areas of
expenditure and many outside observers
including the US Defense Department see
China spending much much more than they
announced so even the top line is opaque
and our best guess though is that china
is increasing its investments in power
projection capabilities this means
seapower long-range conventional
ballistic and cruise missiles advanced
air power and the kinds of systems c4isr
systems that are required to integrate
and utilize these new capabilities
clearly cyber warfare is important to
China's military the people's liberation
army or the PLA on the PLA writes about
the importance of cyber on they talk
about it as an important aspect of
warfare an important new battlefield in
warfare but exactly what kinds of
resources are allocated to that
capability is very very unclear
defense spending is really all it does
is allows you to invest in more military
capabilities it has absolutely nothing
to say about how you use them so if you
look at recent capabilities that China
has been able to feel like an aircraft
carrier advanced surface and subsurface
Kate combatants advanced air fighter
aircraft these are sorts of capabilities
that can be utilized to project Chinese
power further from the Chinese coastline
now whether or not that is used to
confront China's neighbors to assert
capable as claimed Xin in the south
china sea or the East China Sea is
really up to Beijing the capabilities
themselves are agnostic as to how
they're used it's really up to the
people leading China about how these new
capabilities are being utilized